foreign
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the Dollar
Car Rental Studios it's the Ramsay show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice I'm Dave Ramsey your host Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the Ken
Coleman show is my co-host today on the
Ken Coleman show he talks about getting
the job you love getting the work you
love getting involved in work that
matters changing careers all the things
having to do with the income side of the
equation so we'll talk about that and
we'll talk about your money and your
life the phone number is a free call and
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
exciting day here at Ramsay exciting
week here at Ramsey we've got a lot of
launch things this week and we're
kicking off today is launch day for the
pre-sale on Ken's brand new book that
will come out in November start selling
today from paycheck to purpose the clear
path to doing work you love good looking
cover there Ken yeah the team is amazing
just an incredible team here they're
artists to make me look like that Dave
well there's a reason digital adaptation
yes yeah but the uh we have a good
creative team we really do yes help me
with mine too but anyway aside from that
the interior of the book is what's
important it is the most important
that's what changes your life the clear
path you have the seven stages stages
that people go through and you cover all
of them in detail exactly what to do and
really you have to you can't start at
number five you got to start at number
one that's right and you may already
have it done but you got to check it off
that's where you can move on that's
right there's a prerequisite stages they
really aren't it helps you climb the
mountain if we look at doing what you
were born to do the dream job and Legacy
think of it as a mountain and it takes
time some people get up faster than
others so the seven stages are very
simple number one you got to get clear
what is this thing this role that I was
created to fill in the workplace that's
the first thing secondly we got to get
qualified well what does it take to get
qualified this is where a lot of people
Dave get hung up and we walk through the
qualifying questions in the book that
help you create a plan to actually get
qualified well while I'm getting
qualified I can get connected
connections people places that's where I
meet people that bring me opportunities
that was your number one best-selling
book The Proximity it was a deep dive
into get connected stage four is get
started see the connections bring me
opportunities to where I can now step in
and I'm on the ladder now it's about
stepping up that stage five get promoted
you'll spend most of your professional
journey in stage five in that you are
climbing you're moving up and eventually
you get promoted into Stage six get the
dream job this is where you're using
what you do best talent to do work you
love passion to accomplish results that
matter deeply to you Mission when that
alignment happens it is the dream job
and this could be a teacher I mean this
could be a plumber this could be a
professor I mean it is about that
contribution and then what do we do in
that final stage why is there a seventh
stage give yourself away because
nowadays we're not working for income
the income is there
think of our teachers that we found in
the largest study of net worth
millionaires the world has ever seen
that the third largest group of net
worth millionaires were teachers
they're at that point where they've
adjusted their lifestyle they've saved
and their net worth millionaires but
they're not teaching day for income now
it's about impact and let's be honest I
I don't want to embarrass Dave I don't
think he's embarrassable on this but
this is a man who doesn't need to work
he doesn't need to work he's worth a
whole lot of money Dave is here for
income excuse me impact there I said it
I slipped no but you're here for impact
Dave I want the income too oh thank you
well you've got some really nice toys as
well but but you work now because of
impact it's about Legacy and so that's a
quick snapshot of the seven stages we do
a deep dive in the book there's two
chapters on each stage and the purpose
is to give you tactical steps to be able
to do this I tell you what to do and how
to do it and the why to do it and you
can get there the book is from paycheck
to purpose
the clear path to doing what you love by
Ken Coleman it launches today on
pre-sale you will actually have it
shipped to your home if you buy it today
uh in November November the 9th is the
street date and that's when the official
book tour and everything will begin why
would you buy a book in August that you
don't get until November because we're
going to bribe you that's fine we're
going to pay you to do it that's right
we're going to give you so much goodies
in the pre-sale that it makes you want
to buy it ahead of time we are Shameless
in that in our generosity to you guys so
here's the deal you get about a hundred
dollars worth of stuff included in the
book and you can choose between the get
hired bonus pack or the get promoted
Bonus Pack if you're already hired and
you're in the job you're like you just
want to get promoted then you're further
up the steps you need a different set of
things and again there's a hundred
dollars worth of items in there
including the e-book including the
audiobook as read by the author
including lots of other goodies that
will help you on the journey along the
way we've got live event streams coming
up we've got a lot live streaming coming
up with Ken we've got some TED Talks
type stuff that he's doing type things
he's not doing Ted talk but that short
version of get get right in your face
and show you what to do uh all all of
that is there and we're having a lot of
fun celebrating the pre-order launch
with a 500 cash giveaway every week this
month on the website and a grand prize
of three thousand dollars at the end of
August wow so all of this happens at
ramseysolutions.com so enter for your
chances to uh win the Ramsey cash
giveaway go ahead and get your book on
order now and some of the items will
come to you immediately and the ones
that are associated with the actual book
launch itself on like the e-book or the
audiobook you'll get all of that in
November and it's a hundred dollars
worth of stuff that you get when you
pre-order and of course that helps Ken
with the best seller list and so forth
the pre-orders do
and it helps you because you get um you
know a lot of stuff for only 20 bucks
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love
something happens when Monday morning
is no longer
a dread yeah
yeah something happens and it changes
your body chemistry
it changes your attitude towards your
spouse and kids it changes your attitude
towards generosity when you can come in
and do work that you love on Monday
morning you're more creative
you're more productive when you know
that the work that you're doing matters
yes sir you're more creative you're more
productive you smile more you're
literally your body chemistry changes Dr
John and deloney can tell us all about
that oh there's a question that's how I
call it the juice on the Ken Coleman
show you're walking around with some pep
in your step versus Eeyore and the
reality is is because we as human beings
we long to make a difference there's two
primary emotions Dave around work and
it's in the title of the book number one
provision we got to provide
but then we also want to make a
contribution we want to make a
difference and when you do that on
Monday mornings watch how you move up
the ladder because people want to
promote you because they say this is
what you were born to do so it's
possible you can get there income and
impact this is the way to do it yeah we
do onboarding every two weeks at Ramsey
and this morning 15 new team members
started I was excited yes to come to
work this morning and introduce and meet
some all at eight o'clock this morning
before staff meeting started at 8 30 I
always do that as a traditional let the
CEO come in and uh I'm excited that
today is the book launch day yes and
tomorrow we've got other things coming
there's all kinds of goodies happening
this week I want to come to work yeah
we're making a difference and it's fun
which means you guys got us in a good
mood when you call today triple eight
eight two five five two two five
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today the brand new book from paycheck
to purpose the clear path to doing work
You Love by Ken Coleman is now available
on pre-sale as of today at
ramseysolutions.com Ryan is with us in
Wasilla Alaska hi Ryan how are you
I'm good how you doing thank you uh for
taking my call sure what's up
so uh I'm in line for a promotion and
I've been denied the promotion a few
times I want to know how to move forward
for the promotion
what kind of information do you have
from the previous times you've been
denied or time they tell you why
yes so um most of it was uh so when I
first got into the industry I uh came in
at the very rock bottom and I uh it was
kind of like a jokester you know I had
to make everybody smile and I didn't
think that you know this would have been
my career job
um then I got my eyes opened up
when I had taken a business trip and
then found out that this is kind of what
I want to do
and I think my past is coming back to
haunt me a little bit and I wanted to
know how to move forward past you know
moving forward out of this hole so did
they tell you that they think you don't
take your work seriously was that
specific feedback you got
no it was more of I need to gain the
respect of the others around okay great
how long ago was this when you you were
last
it's been about six months six months
okay and are you technically qualified
to to get this position besides the
personal brand kind of what people think
about you and gaining some more respect
are you qualified uh in every other
facet to actually do this job
absolutely okay great so we talk about
this in the book Dave there's there's
five qualities that make a person
promotable and here's the great news
about this Ryan whether you're a zero or
a nine you can move up this is all about
personal development it's really
character and I think for you there's
two that I would focus on of the five I
would focus on the reliability and I
would focus on coachability okay I think
if you are going to your current leaders
maybe even some peers
that might be a little bit older than
they may not be a direct report and I
think you're asking questions sitting
down with pencil and paper and saying
hey what are some areas that I can get
better and what are some ways that I can
get better once they've identified that
and then I would go over the top with
being super reliable this is just simply
you know what uh somebody asked me to do
something not only do I do it I do it
faster than they expected I do it better
than expected and I might add a third
one in here which is likability and then
you're a very fun-loving guy sounds like
but you gotta you gotta make sure that
you know you you kind of adjust okay I I
was a prankster here I'm going to learn
the right time to do that maybe I'm
doing that at lunch and after hours but
I'm gonna serious I'm gonna kind of
tighten things up on this serious spell
but I think if you do that and you show
an overall hunger Say Hey I want to get
better and I want to know how to get
better and then you deliver the results
you can't just ask the questions you
can't just have the one-on-ones you have
to actually change I think if you do
that you're going to show yourself as a
guy who's changed that personal brand
the image the perception of yourself
that's the best way to do it very very
good
make sure that when you do other
people's work for them that you don't
take the credit
um okay and let them to have the credit
you go ahead and just serve serve
everybody around you
find who you can serve how you can help
my friend John Maxwell always says how
can I add value
how can I add value to your life how can
I add value to our friendship how can I
add value to our marriage how can I add
value to your workplace and if I can add
value then guess what you're gonna
you're gonna want me around and uh that
that's just you think about the friends
in your life the ones that when you're
moving they they disappear or the ones
that they show up early with a pickup
you know and um you know that's a
measure of a friend right there because
I'd rather I'd rather take a bullet than
help you move I'm just saying you know
it's like a root canal but I mean stuff
like that inside the workplace find out
what somebody's doing and reach over and
pick up an end of it and help them carry
it and then make sure they get the
credit for all the wonderful work they
did and uh with it with a slight smile
not a jokester smile not a sarcastic
smile but just a grin that just says I
got your back man I'm here for you and
you do that with everybody you work with
it's your peers you won't have to point
it out how good you are other people
will do that for you it'll take a little
time
because a damaged reputation is what
you've got and you're repairing a
damaged reputation so give it a little
time
um but I think you're very promotable
and the main thing that I reason I think
that is you've had your wake-up call and
you've got this level of humility yes I
like you just talking to you and I might
not have liked the you that started
there though
because you know you're screwing off you
were mailing it in you didn't take
anything seriously if you're in a
manufacturing setting you're dangerous
you know in that setting and so you know
whatever it is but but the guy that's
asking this question is a cool guy yeah
I think he's likable yeah he's realized
okay I see what I did I see how I
established this reputation but he's not
deterred by it he wants to get past it
Dave you said something that's huge
certainly for a young man like this
patience is absolutely the wonder drug
here you got to be patient takes time to
turn a reputation around and you've got
to be patient because some people won't
arrive at the conclusion that you want
them to as quick as you'd like but
that's okay be patient do not quit it's
going to pay off for him the Bible says
a good reputation is more valuable than
silver and gold yeah and it is and it's
hard to get one and easy to lose one yes
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Cameron's with us
in Beaufort South Carolina hi Cameron
how are you
hey I'm great how are you guys doing
today better than I deserve what's up
hey my wife and I have a a question
about what to do after baby step three
uh we're expecting our first baby in
December and
um thank you thank you and we're
planning on moving next August
um so we've made the decision to kind of
put everything on hold and go ahead and
stack up as much cash as possible until
the baby's born but then we also are
considering just keeping everything on
hold until the move and just trying to
pile up as much as we possibly can and
then after that if that if that's the
right thing to do where do we end up
moving that money my wife would like to
move it into
our retirement accounts no because she's
a disabled veteran no and she gets okay
no it's not retirement money and you're
screwing around stuff there you don't
need to you're not gonna make any money
on it between now and next August anyway
we're talking about a thousand bucks
here or something you're gonna make okay
it's not it's not well this is
this would be after August after we have
the money collected where would where
then would we do it
well so she's a disabled veteran and she
has told me that she gets
um zero percent down yeah
um loan through the VA yeah so you want
to go if you want to get a big mortgage
and keep a big mortgage I can't help you
with that I'm the guy that tells you get
out of mortgages
well that's what that's what we had been
kind of you know going between I was
saying there's not enough benefit the
benefit for being a disabled veteran and
getting a VA loan is that you don't have
to pay all the funding fees and the
other stuff but it's still a stinking
mortgage
sure sure
it's still a debt it's still something
that's between you and being wealthy so
no that doesn't mean that you might use
the VA loan as a disabled veteran it
might be cheaper maybe it's kind of
borderline okay then a conventional loan
but you still want the smallest possible
mortgage on the shortest possible term
okay let me still want to get out of
debt so we're going to use all this
money towards the house
and then one last question let me stop
just a second okay because I want to
make sure with the chuckle that you
understood
yes because that's the baby steps if you
want to work your wife's plan you guys
go work your wife's plan I'm not gonna
be mad at you we'll be friends but if
you tell me you're on baby step four
this is the plan
got it okay and I think that's why he's
chuckling I think he knew what you were
going to say but the wife's telling him
something different I think we have a
relationship issue here I think we got
to sit down and get on the same page I
think he believes in the baby steps I
think wife's telling himself let's ask
him he's still here
is that Cameron what what is Ken Wright
um yeah I mean partially she's you know
she she believes in a lot of what you
guys talk about but she's she's kind of
behind the on the curve of you know okay
well then you guys need to decide that
Ken's exactly right yeah that's that's
what I was thinking so yeah you know are
we going to work our plan or are you
going to work the baby steps it's up to
you Dave's got a track record I'm gonna
throw that out there yeah I don't know
about her yeah I got a few million have
done this
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Joplin Missouri Chris and Sarah are
calling says on my screen you guys are
debt free congratulations
[Music]
it'll help if I push the button there we
go one more time see that's too much
information you people should have I
should act like it's Kelly's fault but I
didn't I just said it was mine because
it was so Chris and Sarah how are you
great Dave it's good to talk to you
we're good you too finally it was a long
time I've been waiting to talk to you so
tell me how much debt you paid off
paid off
624. in 24 months yeah and uh range of
income during that two years what was
your range
started off with
when we ended with around 110 000. wow
nice jump in two years what do you guys
do for a living
my wife is a first grade school teacher
and I'm a group leader with a 3M Company
here in here in Nevada Missouri so
where'd you get the extra 40 000 in
income in two years
well
um I had a big jump in pay and uh
um I had a couple of uh side hustles
that I did and do I worked uh retail
sales job and uh when I jumped to work
at 3M I was able to uh uh jump off that
job and and stay there full time and and
the pay has been great and I've been
working lots of overtime wonderful good
for you guys what kind of debt was the
51 000.
um credit cards and personal loans and
uh just to tell you I've had a real bad
trouble most of my life uh being honest
and uh and uh I've just kind of had the
mentality that I kind of wanted to
add the uh
idea of keeping up with the Joneses
wanted to you know get ahead and uh
um we did do a attended FPU class one
time about 13 years ago where we were
invited and we just kind of thought well
it's a good plan but we tried to follow
it but then we just kind of went off on
our on our own track and it was more or
less my my issues and not any of my
family I I kind of went off on my own
tangent and did things without my wife
and kids knowing and but uh thank the
Lord for forgiveness and uh
um
because of God's grace our family is
intact loving the Lord
and because you have pointed Us in
directions and given us principles to go
by
um you know we are living life well and
thriving in our finances and in other
areas and we appreciate you and we thank
you for the principles you've given us
but we give all of our praise and glory
to our Lord and maker Jesus Christ amen
for his healing that he's given to us
and we thank you so much uh for the
principles that you've laid out to help
us and guide us in our path you guys and
we're thankful to
um
our
Ramsey Financial coach Tara Russell from
Overland Park she was one that we got
hooked up with and she has just been
such a blessing to us a great guide to
help us setting up our budget and uh
it's just tackling our debt snowball and
just keeping up with us each each and
every month with our budget so monthly
meetings our kids live out of envelopes
we live out of envelopes
kind of a going joke that even the cat
lives out of an envelope so everybody
has envelopes and only so much money to
spend on the budget and when the money's
gone that's it for the month so that
works I love it so it sounds like um
there was an amazing amount of
transformation that happened all through
your lives and the money piece uh once
the rest of that stuff started kicking
in the rest of that transformation
started kicking in the money piece might
have been easy compared
yes yes and I was able to Sarah and I
were able to teach an FPU class at our
church and that you know was just added
momentum for us to you know to be able
to share our story with others and to
you know be able to help other people
have their lives changed and and it's
just been such a great blessing
um what is the word you would use to
describe
uh where you've landed from where you
were
peace peace yes yes a huge amount of
peace
we know where the money's going and uh
there's there's no question about that
anymore that's a change of Lifestyle not
just financially but it you know that
bleeds through other areas of your life
in every single area when when one area
is really messed up yeah it sounds it
sounds like trust and cleanliness go
with it as well yes yes yeah yeah I'm
actually a tree that we planted a member
of our church we have a great loving
church and a member of our church gave
us an acorn and we planted it at
Christmas and each of our children
um to pick the Bible verse that meant a
lot to them imprison I did too and we
planted that Acorn at Christmas time
with those Bible verses in the dirt
and that acorn tree is growing into we
hope and we pray a strong oak tree like
our family is becoming and it's very
symbolic for us yeah truly changing our
family tree Chris I was going to ask you
and Sarah did the Brokenness that you
just shared with our audience did that
lead you to uh the FPU principles and
trying to figure that out or did the FPU
principles and and getting the money
part did it help you move into the
healing on the Brokenness or was it a 50
50. I'm just curious about that you know
I would tend to say and I'll let Chris
say his own I would tend to say both
ways there was bleed over in both ways
uh you know when you when you have
issues going on you know they need to be
fixed just not sure how to do it yeah
and um whenever we start fixing in one
area well that's going to bleed over and
start fixing other areas which did
happen not just because it happened but
because the Lord allowed it to happen
and helped us and your principles guided
us along that way yeah that's powerful
here that's so powerful I just want to
say this real quick you too the the
belief in the money tactics
uh sounds like it bled over into the
belief in getting healthy in other areas
and that's a powerful thing
yeah and for me when it was when I had I
was down and I had
I had reached the bottom I mean I
tried to do everything on my own and I
had realized that uh
if you put your faith in complete faith
and trust in Christ and
everything else will fall together the
money part came with it but when you put
your faith and trust in Christ and uh
it's just an amazing transformation and
uh you know there was desire there to
get things right but when you're not
sure how to do it and you're scared
you're scared because you don't know
what to do and you don't know what to
pay first and you just don't know what
to do but your principles helped us and
our financial coach Tara Russell she
pointed us and she always refers back to
you every single meeting we have with
her she refers back to Dave and she
helped point us in the right direction
uh following your principles you guys
are incredible yeah we got a copy of the
Legacy Journey that's the next chapter
in your story you have changed your
legacy and that tree as you said very
symbolic of this change you don't have
our mortgage to pay off
mortgage and actually we want to come to
Tennessee when we pay our mortgage off
we want to do the that free scream in
person we'll let you do we'll let you do
number two version two when you do that
absolutely we'll be honored to have you
guys and a copy of Total Money Makeover
as well on which you guys can give away
and pay it forward and the kiddos are
going to join you in the debt free
scream
their names
Annabelle is our oldest and Emma is our
second oldest by the way those two girls
are in college and I just want to let
you know they live Dave principles
they're living on a budget and they live
out of envelopes also very good our son
James is 14 and our daughter Ella is
eight all right 51 000 paid off in 24
months making 71 to 110 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three three two one
[Applause]
I love it
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today launching his brand new book on
pre-sale today from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to doing work you love
goes on sale today the actual launch
date's November the 9th all kinds of
goodies when you pre-order the book all
for 20 bucks about a hundred dollars
worth of stuff be sure and check it out
ramseysolutions.com Patrick's in Dallas
hi Patrick welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
I um just want to say you know a big fan
of you and me and my wife have been
following the baby steps for the past
couple months and it's made a real big
impact in our lives and it's going
really great so um thank you for that
cool my question today is more for Ken
um I've been listening to a lot of Ken
Coleman show and you know working
towards finding my dream job and I
actually have a question for him
um so I currently work for a great
company and have a great leader but it
isn't exactly my dream job
um I've already put in my resignation to
my current job and I'm starting work
next week at another company that is
much more aligned with my career goals
my question today is it appropriate for
me to ask my current boss for a
reference letter before I leave my
current position to be used possibly in
a future job search sure I don't know
why it would be based on what you told
me it was a great company and you have a
great you have a lot of admiration for
your leader uh and assuming that you
didn't burn the bridge and there wasn't
a kind of a nasty ugly tension-filled uh
process in leaving sure I would
absolutely feel like that's appropriate
no I actually um I gave him a three
weeks notice and um he was real
supportive and uh you know said of
course you know I'm gonna miss you but
you know wish you the best of luck and
he he kind of agrees that he thinks it's
a good it's a good move for me yeah it's
a no-brainer say look uh yeah you've
been a lot to me I learned a lot I've
already landed the new job I don't need
it for that but just because I admire
you I'd like to have a letter from you
in the file yeah you should do that I
think he'll feel honored and uh I think
that's a good move absolutely
appropriate
I appreciate it sure worst thing you can
do say no yeah and you still got your
job so it's no big deal but great on
Patrick that's the way you want to leave
you want your leader to say that about
you if you do it right and you have a
healthy leader there's two pieces of
that equation and both of those seem
like great people there Jake is on the
line in Portland Oregon Hey Jake welcome
to the Ramsey Show
I am doing better than I do
there how can we help
all right so first of all just thank you
very much for uh for your program my
wife and I paid off about 130 000 on the
student loan debt a while back and we
were living debt free wow cool
yeah so my question is related to
education So currently I'm working at a
job open for about a year and a half I'm
eight years out of college
um and I'm looking at building an MBA
it's always been on my radar they have a
wonderful education uh assistance
program
um that I basically was in line for
about all the way through the process of
getting classes registered I took the
test I got all the fees paid and I got
all the way to the top and I got
basically put on hold for the assistance
and so I need to make a decision whether
I just need to pursue the MBA anyways or
hold off till potentially next year and
try again why do you want the NBA is it
just something you've always wanted to
do or you need it that's the key word
caps n-e-e-d do you need it to get where
you want to go
um well looking at my leadership in my
company I don't think I don't think I
need it not everyone has an advanced
degree
um I'm an engineer I have an engineering
degree I feel like the business side of
things would complement that I'd have
the technical I'd have the business
action in that's what the original goal
was I do have a business minor that kind
of set me up for this that's why it's
been in my radar but uh that's the tough
part it's not I'm a little confused why
they turn on and off the
uh tuition assistance
yeah
yeah is where it was going to be
approval process it goes through all the
layers of management
that was told by
my direct manager that it was looking
good and we were going forward and I
couldn't so I don't approve everybody
for this why do they not approve them
they didn't give me good enough the
answer I kind of gleaned from the
conversation was that I wasn't there
long enough I've been there a year and a
half
um but I was on the right path is what
they were saying but that's nothing to
do with the the fine print said nothing
about how long you'd be at the company
is that he could be there a minimum of
one year which I had at the time so many
people worked on this company
um
a lot I would say it's a large it's a
large company actually part of a
conglomerative company so 100 000 or
more
uh yeah okay
yeah that's a lot okay good all right I
just didn't know because we have a
tuition assistance program and yeah we
won't approve it for uh if you want to
be a nurse because we don't need nurses
and we want to pay for you that do that
but if you're doing something if you're
learning something that has applicable
inside this building it's 100 approved
all the time it's very easy but we're a
smaller company we're only a thousand
folks yeah so yeah there's about 5 000
in my in my sites my area and I'm
guessing it's somewhat competitive is
that true as well
yeah it's not like yeah one person
but yeah listen I'd sit tight yeah going
back to what we said you don't need it
it would be nice uh certainly an NBA is
a good thing but we want to cash flow it
and we would love to get the assistance
and I think with the work you've done
I'd sit tight I'd take them at heart uh
what they said and I'd go do everything
I could to show them that I've put in
the time I've put in the effort I am now
a candidate and I'd keep signing up with
a good attitude I'd wait right now I
would not move into it yourself yeah no
reason to pay for it Justin's in Raleigh
hey Justin welcome to the Ramsay show
how you doing Mr Ramsey good better not
deserve how can we help
all right so
um I just kind of stumbled across your
teachings I haven't really dived into it
yet but I am in 90 000 worth of you know
overall cumulative debt debt and uh I'm
just kind of like at a loss of like
should I should file bankruptcy what
should I do especially when I have
um like garnishments coming against me
or starting to come against me so
scary time sir
yes sir so uh what do you make it what's
your household income are you married
uh no so single okay what do you make
um that's about
um 40 000 a year okay what are the
garnishments on
the garnishment is on this uh old credit
card debt it's like five thousand uh
dollars total on that one uh they tell
you they were going to garnish you or
they actually turned it into your
employer
uh they actually so I had a
um garnishment hearing today okay so
okay they're really doing it okay and um
what other what other kind of debts are
in the 90 000.
all right so
um I do have seventy thousand dollars
student loans
have about
ten thousand dollars
collectively with you know just credit
card debt
um eight thousand dollars just medical
bills and other like unsecured debt and
you're working 40 hours
well I'm working right now I'm working
about 50 60 so I'm taking all the
overtime I can get really that leaves
you at 40 000 income no I just started
this new job I was a teacher before okay
so with you working on this OT what are
you gonna be making
uh I expect to make about between 50 55
when it's all said and done well here's
the bad news is you're not bankrupt
here's the good news is you're not
bankrupt student loans are not
bankruptible
right so you wouldn't file bankruptcy on
twenty thousand bucks man
you go to work and work on a plan and
work your way through this you got to
beat this garnishment off with a
settlement offer of some kind if you got
any money at all
not on hand I could probably liquidate I
do have like 500 in a like stock
portfolio from Robin Hood that I can
liquidate and do
let's start Gathering some money
together and try to offer the people
that are garnishing you about 20 cents
on the dollar if you can which on five
thousand bucks that'd be a thousand
dollars right and see if you can get a
settlement going with them to settle
this don't offer it as a payment it's a
settlement in full uh here's what we're
going to do I've been where you are I'm
I've been scared like you are I know how
it feels and I'm not going to leave you
hanging with a short radio answer I'm
going to put you into Ramsey plus to go
through Financial Peace University I'm
going to pay for it and Kelly's going to
hook you up with one of our financial
coaches and help you walk your way
through this so you don't file
bankruptcy no charge We're not gonna
charge you a dime you're not bankrupt
you're just scared and don't know your
way out and we'll show you how this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the Ramsey show if
you would like to do your debt free
screen live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsayshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to Nashville
and tell Dave your story
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the Dollar
Car Rental Studios it's the Ramsey show
where debt is dumb Cassius king and the
paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice I'm Dave Ramsey your host you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host today and so
we'll be taking your calls about career
as well the Ken Coleman show on 75 radio
stations SiriusXM a podcast and
everywhere else that you can get any
kind of Ramsay network uh information
he's there he's all over the place
answering your questions about your life
and your career so jump in the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five it is launch day here
at Ramsey we are launching Ken's brand
new book and pre-sale it will be a
number one bestseller following his last
number one bestseller it's called from
paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love you can pre-order the book at
ramseysolutions.com it's twenty dollars
and we will throw in a hundred dollars
worth of goodies to bribe you to
pre-order it so all kinds of good stuff
there the audio book The e-book and a
lot of other different things depending
on whether you're trying to get promoted
or whether you're just getting started
and you're trying to get clear something
else we're launching today can in
addition to your book congratulations on
that by the way thank you so exciting
what a great day
we're also launching the get clear
assessment that our team has been
working on with you our product team has
spent a bazillion hours on this with you
and it is absolutely incredible it's an
assessment process that you take and it
will help you to get clear on what you
should be doing that will give you Joy
yeah this is the million dollar question
and so many people struggle to answer
what should I do with my life and so we
give you a about a 25 minute experience
asking questions like I do with folks on
air and we're going to give you a report
on what you do best talent and then what
work you love to do passion and then the
results that you most want to create
with your work and we give you a nice
detailed report it's simple but it's so
clear and then the best part is we're
going to populate a purpose statement
for you we take those results your top
three talents top three passions and
then that driver that missional result
that you most want out of your work and
we put it in a purpose statement and
then it keeps going then we're going to
give you some professional possibilities
we show you now these aren't guarantees
we say this is an area or two or three
or four where this purpose statement
aligns with work that would be something
that you would be very good at really
enjoy and it produces a result that
connects to your values and so what
happens is Dave it really is this giant
kind of crystal ball of clarity hey
there are many paths to the dream job
for me many different Industries and see
what people get locked up with is they
think well it's just one answer it's
only one thing and it's a very
terrifying Prospect so it really is the
methodology that's underneath the first
stage of the seven stages get clear and
we're going to give you that assessment
when it prints out or you can keep it on
your computer it's going to give you
tremendous Clarity to move forward and
then we give you the steps of course in
the book
you know from paycheck to purpose and
that's how I get up the mountain but I
gotta first know the mountain I want to
climb so it's a great product the team's
done a great job Dave with the digital
experience and it's here's the thing
about this
this is going to tug at your heart and
your brain yes not your outside
variables that's right okay so once you
get clear the next step is you get
qualified so for instance like if you
ever took one of those old career
assessments back in the day uh you know
like in high school or something
um you know like I have a friend who's a
a microbiologist now who makes a
bazillion dollars in research and when
he took one of those things that told
him he ought to be a custodian oh yeah
slightly missed there yeah a little miss
little miss on that so but they were
analyzing his outside variables his
current level of education and grade
point that kind of stuff we don't do any
of that no this is all about what makes
you tick what you're naturally good at
weaving those together yes sir to help
you get clear on a direction that you
need to go that'll cause you to be in a
job being a career that well Monday
morning you're smiling it's exactly
right you get excited even on the long
days the hard days you go this was worth
it when I drive home and you know you
know Psalm 139 David writes so
beautifully he's he's writing and he's
saying you knit me together in my
mother's womb and you're right Dave this
assessment the the get clear career
assessment from Ramsey Solutions turns
you Inward and you begin to see who you
really are who you were created to be
it's not a big mystery Talent passion
Mission all of us come into this world
hardwired and it really is The Head and
the Heart coming into alignment it's
really fun it's eye-opening it's
enlightening their ahas and then
practical steps to actually do something
about it we don't just say oh here's
seven to ten or Twenty things you could
do no we point you in that direction and
then we teach you even in the assessment
and we Deep dive in the book from
paycheck to purpose how to clarify and
verify further and actually no this is
an incredible tool that if you went to
some kind of career coach or something
you pay 300 to take oh yeah I mean it's
it's detailed it's going to spit out a
report that you're gonna go oh my gosh
they just read the mail
and uh so the get clear assessments you
can get it online at
ramseysolutions.com of course
um or here's a better idea go ahead and
pre-purchase Ken Coleman's book for
twenty dollars get the hundred dollars
worth of stuff and for another 10 bucks
we'll throw in the 30 assessment
otherwise if you just go buy it it's 30
bucks or you can get all that stuff for
30 bucks yeah incredible so don't go
just buy for 30 bucks go buy the whole
bundle and get the assessment with it
and the assessment will download
immediately you can use this now you
don't have to wait till November to do
it and then you'll get the book and the
other things associated with the book in
November when the book actually comes
out so that's the ultimate career bundle
on the new book from paycheck to purpose
now if you just want to go buy the
assessments you can do that we'll take
your 30 bucks but I'm just telling you
how to get a better deal that's the
whole thing and
you know you talk about uh
knit you in your mother's womb Ray Bakke
talks about that word knit
in the Hebrew is very similar to the
word crochet yes and my grandmother she
used to crochet when I was a kid
crocheted blankets and everything and uh
I got my man card back but at one point
she taught me how to crochet so Dave
Little Dave was a crocheter for a short
period of time to get in my granny's
good graces because she would cook you
anything and
um so but you know Baki talks about can
you imagine the maker of heaven and
Earth with a couple of crochet needles
that's right going okay RNA double in it
RNA DNA double helix
oh that's a good one you're fearfully
and wonderfully made yeah he says every
time he does that
RNA DNA double helix ah knit you right
there you were made to do something you
talk about that all the time and finding
out what that is the day you know why
you're here is a powerful day
yes it's not enough though Dave just to
know you got to do it here's what I tell
people you are created to fill a unique
role in your work you are needed you
must do it somebody out there needs you
to show up and give yourself away in
your work and then the income and impact
they come with that they're super
excited about it the new book is from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work you love the new assessment
is the get clear assessment all of it at
ramseysolutions.com all bundled together
all at Bargains do not miss out on this
this is life-changing material Coleman's
putting out here Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsay personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your
careers your money your life right here
on the Ramsay show Lee is with us in
Omaha Nebraska hi Lee how are you
hi Dave hi Ken I'm doing great
cool how can we help
uh my wife and I just finished uh paying
off our debt snowball uh 325 thousand
dollars and we're busting through step
three and so here in the next month or
so we'll be ready to invest
and so my question is how much do I
start investing
um I know it's 15 but we only got a few
months left here so gotta try to go for
that whole Gusto and the whole 12 months
time or just break it down into the last
quarter
okay you're gonna be doing the rest of
your life
so we're gonna put it on a monthly basis
so what is your annual income
uh combined about 160. okay
and so you're going to be putting in
about uh 27 28 000 okay
and so you're gonna be putting in about
twenty four hundred twenty three hundred
bucks a month some into something that's
what it amounts to okay and
um somewhere in that range I mean just
divide it out right uh your income times
fifteen percent is your annualized
amount then divide that into your
monthly because you're going to start
putting that much into your 401k your
Roth IRA your Roth 401k with or without
a match and all of those things to get
up to the twenty thousand dollar or yeah
to the 20 something thousand dollar Mark
to get you to exactly 15 of that and um
so yeah that's that's the route to go uh
instead of trying to do fits and starts
and just do lump sums and then next year
you've got to figure it out and then the
next year you got to figure it out and I
just set it on a monthly thing it's
automatic and you just keep doing it and
keep doing it and keep doing it and
before you know it you'll be a baby
steps millionaire Amanda's in Omaha
Nebraska hi Amanda how are you
hi Mr Ramsey nice to meet you you too
how can Ken and I help
um well I am I need help worth juggling
and prioritizing
um some things I called Ken before
um I so what I'm juggling is Passion
project career skills debt and my
personal limitations those four things
and I'm not doing very good at getting
any particular thing done so okay well
you need to give us a little bit more of
a breakdown so let's talk about the debt
first
okay debt uh 50 000 I currently make
forty five thousand I'm a digital
marketer
okay what's the 50 000 in debt what is
it comprised of
uh it is student loan debt uh medical
bills and stupid debt credit card okay
how much of it is student loan debt
um about 40 most of it is student loan
debt okay all right so now uh the
passion project you ran through things
pretty quick give me the rest of the
list the passion project was one and
what else
project career skills debts and
limitations and the passion project is
um you know what I'm what I'm so driven
to do is
um it is author I um I write a lot I
really want to make that a side career
I've got lots of stories I want to start
publishing them I want to keep writing I
want to finish things too I'm not doing
very good with that okay well we've got
a lot going on here let me quickly
address the passion project okay there's
nothing keeping you from writing right
now in fact the best way to become a
writer is to write now that does not
mean that you're published does that
mean you have a big literary deal it
means that you are writing and you can
write in short form on Instagram you can
create a blog for next to nothing but uh
there you know I know a lot of uh people
who are world-class writers so Dave and
I both are mutual friends and every time
I've ever talked to them uh when they
give advice to people who ask them
questions it's just always be writing so
you need to write write write that has
nothing to do with the rest is about
that is you can do that while other
people are asleep yeah and while you're
working multiple jobs to get out of debt
you need to get out of debt and here's
what I think is going to happen I think
if you if you walk out the baby steps
and you see momentum there I think
you're going to see momentum in the rest
of these areas of your life and then I
want to ask you about limitations you
mentioned limitations what is that
what are you referring to
um in a major depressive episode since
about 2018 so
um I so even when I sometimes I'm doing
great other times even though I plan to
right or to work on you know like a
Google certifications or something I
just struggle with getting out of bed so
just occasionally sometimes that stuff
will come up and my my plans will get
kind of tossed it out of it I get that
okay so
um I'm not a licensed counselor but I
believe in counseling and this
depression is a real thing and you need
to get help there and so I think the
focus of of where you are and where you
need to be is I think you need to get
help with the depression that is
debilitating stuff you need to see a
professional on that I would also uh if
you don't go to church I consider going
to church and also get some spiritual
input and surround yourself with some
people who really believe in you this is
beyond the counseling the second thing
is I really want you we'll get you help
but I want you to get serious about this
debt I think if you can day job this
right now and you get out of debt while
getting the counseling and getting
Victory with depression getting over
that and be able to manage that not
getting over but managing that
um I think that that is your priority
right now and the writing as you get as
you begin to get healthy and even in the
process don't wait write about the stuff
that you're depressed about put your
heart Let it bleed on the pay paper and
you can show that work or you don't have
to but you can develop the skill of
writing along the way but right now the
debt and the depression I think Dave are
her priorities you already seeing
somebody hun
yeah yeah I'm being a counselor so are
you making progress
well it's never progress is not
necessarily in a straight line it's just
in a Direction
yeah
yeah
we've been setting up um are you better
today than you were three years ago
two years ago
yeah good that's progress yeah
no Hey listen I'm 60. I'm still making
progress but some days I suck
yeah so that's okay yeah I mean that's
your apostolous that's part of
everybody's life right where you know
this is a tide goes in times it goes out
thing uh the question is uh are we
moving in a Direction so here's the
thing
um talk to your Co your counselor about
this because Kenner on neither one are I
we've I've worked with a lot of manic
depressors over the years a lot of
bipolar uh because you generally have
financial trouble it goes with the
territory okay
um and the more extreme the case the
more extreme the financial trouble so
you're you're uh coming out of this and
you're starting to get some healing and
you're starting to head the right
direction so your finances are starting
to pop up now and light up and you know
you're beginning to attack that so I I
think this is a really great example
where two things that you can complete
will provide you two
helps for the depression now verify this
with your coach your counselor because
I'm not one but as my understanding is
like you said completing things is a big
deal
yeah because the confidence that that
gives you affects the chemical releases
in your body and affects the depression
so the sense of Confidence from
completing something like your smallest
debt in your debt snowball okay or like
writing a Blog not a novel
yeah yeah okay uh and so completing
things the second thing that those two
things give you that'll uh that assist
in the process of working through the
depression is activity
and activity is
um is the enemy of depression inactivity
as its friend
when you know when you lay in bed it
gets worse not when you go for a run
yeah you know and so that's human nature
because again you're physically
completing things you're even if you're
sitting at the keyboard I'm going to
force myself to complete this Debt Pay
yeah one down or I'm going to force
myself to complete this blog and uh it
doesn't have to be a big old bites it's
just got to be something that keeps you
moving and builds your confidence and I
think your therapist will verify yeah
that those are two positive things you
can do in this situation again I'm not
qualified other than 30 years of doing
what I do and working with a lot of
folks where you are and I got to tell
you there's a lot of Hope for folks that
are pushing against that that black dog
as Winston Churchill called it and
um it's uh it's it can be defeated it
can be it is a process and it is real
but it can be defeated and I think
you're on your way kiddo I'm proud of
you well done this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage Ben and Justine are with
us hey how are you guys not too bad
welcome welcome where do you all live St
Louis Missouri awesome and you're here
to do a debt free scream how much have
you paid off uh 73 991 dollars all right
and how long did it take you 24 months
exactly wow and your range of income
during that time 62 000 to 95 000. cool
good what do you guys do for a living
um I'm an uh manager at Aldi and I'm an
occupational therapist awesome very cool
what kind of debt was this 74 000.
almost all of it was student loans we
had a little bit that was a car and then
a little bit of medical debt from the
birth of our son ah how long you all
been married seven years Okay cool so
what happened 24 months ago so about 24
months ago we were just living life
normally but realized that we were so
tired and then we weren't gaining any
traction at all in our lives we had just
moved into our new home we had at that
point our son who was like six months
old and we were working jobs in careers
and just not getting anywhere so we
realized that there were things that we
wanted to do we wanted to be able to go
out as a family we wanted to be able to
buy a microwave for our new home and
there was just no room in the budget or
in our bank account to do so so about it
at that time my brother had moved into
the St Louis area and he had just
graduated college and was getting ready
to start his new job and he was having
dinner with us and he said that he was
getting ready to pay off his student
loans using the baby steps and he asked
us if we had ever heard of you and of
course we said we had then he goes well
have you guys thought about doing the
baby steps and we said well no and he
said well why not he said you guys could
totally do it so at that point I ended
up reading your book The Total Money
Makeover and then Ben ended up watching
a couple of I think your podcasts a
couple of your interviews and at that
point it was game on we knew when we
believed that we could go little brother
whoa how about that I like that yeah so
once we had decided that that was our
future and that was what we were gonna
do as soon as we were both on the same
page there was no stopping us so Ben
ended up actually changing careers right
at the beginning of it from a job that I
would consider probably pretty toxic for
us in many different Realms and into a
new role I stepped into a full-time
position took on another job and we also
watched a ton of dogs over the course of
two years I think it was over like 200
dogs over the course of two years in
order to make this happen you used to
like dogs but not anymore oh my God what
was the rate on watching dogs I'm
curious we watched dogs at about 25 a
night okay so we ended up uh able we
were able to propel our debts mobile
even more yeah
wow everything is game on here yes yeah
we really leaned into it and decided
that that was what we wanted to make
happen and then with he he and I just
together as a team that was what we did
Ben what did you what was the career
change from what to what um I went from
a manager at McDonald's to um uh just a
associate role at Aldi and then
eventually got moved up into a
management role wow okay good for you
that's fun cool very cool it's worked
out well yes worked out well everything
changed yeah what do you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is um I
always give people three three things um
just being on the same page with your
spouse that's number one uh studying a
clear goal and then
um just being uh just being at a mindset
that you're going to get there you know
that you're going to get there
so you guys I mean being on the same
page with your spouse
from the very time you started this you
were on the same page yeah it wasn't
like one of you got drug kicking and
streaming no I would say it took us
YouTube totally makeover book and these
things weaving back and forth bouncing
around your household and finally it all
lands yes yeah and she definitely pushed
me to do that so okay yeah okay
all right so but it wasn't like you you
were ready because you want it out too
though yeah yeah so and uh Wow way to go
little brother that's amazing that's a
great story very cool so uh Justine what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is I think that Ben
um really wrapped it up well um but for
us and for everyone else if you're doing
this with someone else uh being on that
same page because two minds are greater
than one two paychecks are better than
one being together and having that
Bullseye goal um you're going to get
there twice as fast so I tell people to
stay focused as a team and to make sure
that you and your spouse continue or you
know whoever it is that you're going
along this plan and journey with are
together so I gotta ask you I love these
stories because the focus and the
intensity you know it's so incredible
was there a point where you go okay
we're heads down for a while right and
then you look up one day and you go whoa
we're really making some serious
progress I'm just curious when was that
for you and your journey
um I would say about six months in six
months yeah we were we were pretty like
headstrong and then we were like hey we
can do this a couple months ahead of our
goal like let's do this like let's go
head first into it and let's get let's
get it done yeah and at that point at
that point we like
or like extra jobs whatever we can do so
yeah and how many points I had written
all of our debts down and every time we
wrote one we wrote a goal to get there
and every time we kept we're like wait
if we do this we can hit this goal a
couple months faster than we thought we
could you know if we just watch a few
more extra dogs or if we end up picking
up a couple extra shifts you know we're
really gonna get 200 dogs in two years
that's what I was about to ask I'm sorry
how many dogs was there a crazy story
where you had like I just gotta know I'm
into the two minutes the too many Dog
Nights there was that one point there
was one overnight where dogs were coming
in and out of our home and it ended up
being like seven dogs we also have three
young children too I know there's was
one day uh we watched some dogs who
actually had to be diapered and I walked
into my home and I was like I have to
diaper like four living things with
heartbeats right now between children
and dogs so and we only have a 900
square foot house so we're just like
trying to please God tell me you charge
extra for that we ended up we wish but I
tell you you documented the day where
the babies were running around and the
dogs all in diapers please tell me we
have pictures of them
you work like no one else like no one
else that's right you guys are powerful
you're powerful very very well done I'm
so proud of you thank you so your little
brother was cheering you on outside of
the two of you who else is cheering you
on
um just like on my side of the family a
lot of my parents and um my siblings
definitely cheered us on too yeah and my
side of the family also was a big
support for us uh we had family coming
into town we live about an hour to two
hours three hours away from family but
they were coming into town every weekend
so that we could work our jobs and work
our shifts and when they came into our
home that meant they were also watching
the dogs and helping us take care of
them so we had an Incredible family
support a lot of our friends checked in
with us asking us how we were doing you
know what what got what's new for you
guys this week how many of you paid off
like Adventure like an adventure
everybody went on with you absolutely
yeah we had wonderful neighbors too who
put up with all the barking dogs and
knew what we were doing and why we were
doing it as well crazy we really had a
great Village and Community behind us
that's so fun all right so you brought
the kiddos with you what are their names
and names Caroline is five Lucas is
three and then we have our baby Becca
who is one-year-old oh fun well we've
got a copy of the Legacy Journey for you
because that's what you've done for sure
changed your legacy and we've got a copy
of The Total Money Makeover as well
where you can pay it forward to someone
and they can
they
pay it forward to someone else and they
can learn to be how to be on the you
could be like your little brother was to
you yeah just get something and that's
the little brother over there right yeah
I came with you very good all right here
we go Ben and Justine Caroline Lucas and
Becca from St Louis 74 000 paid off in
24 months making 62 to 95. rock stars
look at these Heroes count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
we're debt free foreign
wow
you get the feeling that crew right
there is Unstoppable
yeah hey let me tell you you want to
walk some dogs for some extra money
you want a diaper diaper someone else's
dogs for sure I gotta tell you that's
gazelle that's
that's over the top I'm just safe this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality brand new
book on sale today from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love you can get it at
ramseysolutions.com for 20 on pre-order
get about 150 worth of stuff included
you don't want to miss out on that the
book actually comes out in November but
we're going to bribe you to buy it today
it goes on sale today from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee even if you mess up and you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
Ramsay to get the best possible deal
today's question comes from roneal in
California he says my wife and I are 39
and 40 we make over 230 000 we have 300
000 in Mortgage Debt and 500 000 in
retirement we plan on selling our house
and the next few months where we will
clear between 700 or about 700 000 in
equity we are not happy in our jobs and
do not have passion for the work we've
been doing we want to either ask for six
months unpaid time off or in the worst
case quit and use some of our savings a
little bit less than a hundred thousand
dollars to travel while trying to figure
out what we want to do for the next 10
to 20 years of our career are we being
unwise well you're being very impatient
and I get it when you're Restless you
got to be careful because Restless
people are looking for diversions this
sounds like a diversion here we're going
to travel and use some of our savings
that we've worked hard for and try to
discover what we want to do while
traveling I want you to be diligent
because you can figure this out without
traveling I'm not against traveling but
to ask for six months unpaid time off I
do think is unwise not sure you'd get
that that's essentially fancy form of
quitting and I don't want you to quit
and use that savings when we don't have
something to quit too we want you to
walk to it we want you to walk across
the bridge the seven stages that I
unpack in the new book from paycheck to
purpose does not require you to take a
big leap and I I know what you're
feeling I've been there
but the reality is you can discover what
that next stage is those next seasons
before we quit I don't want you to just
travel go try to find yourself that's an
excuse yeah it's a bad it's an excuse
not to have some escapism that at the
end of this you still are not going to
have landed on anything and then you're
going to be screwed yeah based on what I
have done Dave and what I write about we
don't just travel the world and get
quiet under a tree
falls on us yeah that doesn't work no
here's the thing you need to sell your
house sure and you need to change jobs
yes but you do not need to do your plan
your plan sucks no that's right you're
gonna end up in a mess here dude yeah
because they're in great financial shape
if they pay that what you need to do is
you need to spend some time go ahead and
uh take your vacation time sure you
probably have some sure and use that
time to be introspective uh maybe a
little bit of travel during some of that
spend some money you've got some money
you're not in bad shape financially uh
but you don't need to take six months to
do this and spend some time going okay
I'm gonna get real quiet on the back
porch with a cup of coffee of a cabin in
the woods that is 400 miles away 300
miles away it's not it doesn't have to
be it doesn't have to be you don't have
to go to Europe for five months to find
yourself by the way yourself is not in
Europe yourself is right where it
yourself is could spend 30 minutes Dave
going to ramseysolutions.com and taking
the get clear career assessment then sit
alone underneath the tree and go hey
with all these possibilities that have
been pointed out to me yeah that's
that's each one of these things actually
makes my heart come alive when I think
about doing it and then one more step go
spend time with somebody who's doing
that thing that career path that you
think you want to do get that extra
level of clarity to say tell me about
the good the bad what do you love the
most what do you like the least we make
this decision Dave so mysterious and so
out of touch and we've got to simplify
it and that's what we're doing at Ramsey
Solutions we're saying hey look inward
it's not a worthy of course no you don't
need a Ouija board yeah you need to sit
down and get clear on where you're going
then get qualified to do that and follow
your steps straight through that's it
and you can take that assessment 30
bucks yeah that's a good idea we'll sell
them one of those if I had their name if
we have their contact stuff we'll send
them one but um send them a link to do
it is to get clear assessment it went on
today out with the book and it's
available right this second at
ramsaysolutions.com it's incredible so
if you take that thing and you figure
out who you are then you start to say
okay I'm going to transfer to this job
in this state and so then I sell my
house and I move to that job in that
state yes I don't have to take six
months off without paying no I don't
have to wander the world hoping that
that somehow I'm going to have an
epiphany as I stand at the foot of the
pyramids that's right that's just
complete BS that's right and not
necessary because if you do it the way
that you just laid out Dave the income
is not interrupted right the best part
is the income increases and you're not
going to burn through all the equity in
your house and burn through all your
savings trying to find yourself yeah
while yourself was in front of you all
the time that's really well said that's
really true it's just you go out looking
for yourself and by the way who's with
you while you're doing that yourself
and so you don't need to go looking
they're right there so you know sit down
spend some time maybe even get with a
coach maybe get with a counselor maybe
get with your pastor uh maybe get with
some of your friends who'll dope slap
you into reality and say no you're not
one of those you're one of these you're
not a tiger you're a koala bear you're
not a koala bear you're a tiger what
kind of animal are you you know let's
figure this out you gotta have people
like this sometimes in your life and so
that's part of what that get clear
assessment will do yeah it's this is a
gentle dope slap Dave yeah but this is
how you do it though because I mean have
you not had friends that saved you from
yourself I love that you said that
that's listen that's what you need
sometimes friends that save Me For
Myself doing half the time it's what we
do on this show is we love you so much
we just reach over and go as a friend
here hold this pop yeah so um but yeah
it's that's the thing get clear get
qualified get connected get started get
promoted work through Ken's clear steps
on this they it's not just trying to
sell Ken's stuff dude the bottom line is
you need a plan and wander wondering the
Earth is not your plan no in the name of
I'm burned out and I hate my life and
that just sounds like you know I'm 17
years old and I'm going to go
backpacking in Europe for six months and
find myself you're not 17 you make 230
000 a year you have a half million
dollars in your Investments you're not a
child anymore my son so um you're going
to function through this and lay out a
game plan like an adult have a strategic
game plan and execute the plan
flawlessly at the end of the plan you're
going to be making more money in a
better situation you're going to have
sold the house you're going to be in a
state different than California where
your new career is your whole new life
everything about your new life is going
to be amazing because you game planned
it and then you went and got it yeah and
when you travel you're traveling on
purpose right we're not blowing money
and blowing time we're actually planning
you keep doing it don't travel don't
don't travel to hide no
travel to enjoy yeah don't travel no all
of you people do this if you listen if
your whole reason to go on vacation is
you can hide from your life then you
need to come home change your freaking
life it's true there's something wrong
with that this idea it's not it's like
some kind of escapism yes and of course
these people in the in the Resort World
they Pander to that that we're gonna
have this alternate reality that we get
to go live in for a little while yes and
then we have to come back to our
horrible life that's that's drudgery and
um dude hey I enjoy travel I like my
home too you have a pretty great life
yeah so do I I mean you know this idea
of vacation ought to be about resting
and restoring yourself right yeah
restoration recreating recreating
yourself it's great to resign you know
write that resignation letter but don't
turn it in and go and vacate and restore
and recreate yourself and come back tear
it up and keep on going but this idea of
coming back to this oh I just got to
make it through to next year's vacation
it's really crazy and I'll tell you
something else you know what six months
of unpaid work doing uh six pounds off
from work you hate
you ought to take the rest of your life
off from work you hate right and then
not be unpaid yeah that's what we're
about here yeah you need to change yeah
Direction yeah get the new thing get the
new thing baby get the new thing get you
a Target if you aim at nothing you will
hit it everything that's the truth you
all hit it every time it's a hundred
percent shot that you're gonna miss
because you have no idea what you're
aiming at and other people do Ready Aim
aim aim oh yeah and pull the trigger
that's exactly right oh my God sit
around whine about it pull the trigger
so that's not his problem he's ready to
pull the trigger too fast doesn't have a
game plan so yeah uh but but you know
you got some people get paralysis of the
analysis on the other thing right and
they can't they can't move off their
butt they get stuck on their butt so
it's um it's a problem folks you got to
think through these things and lay it
out and then that that's the beauty of a
clear path that's why the baby steps
work that's why Ken's seven stages work
this clear path keeps you moving right
along right along right along right
along right along it's not a treadmill
it's a trailblaze this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of Ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
Ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the Ramsay
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the Dollar
Car Rental Studios it's the Ramsey show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off Home Mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice I'm Dave Ramsey your host Ken
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
today's book launch day as we launch the
pre-sale on his brand new book from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work that you love it's twenty
dollars if you pre-order it you get a
hundred and fifty dollars hundred
dollars plus worth of stuff going with
it check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com the phone number
here triple eight eight two five five
two two five Cody's in Providence Rhode
Island hi Cody welcome to the Ramsay
show
thank you Dave thanks for taking my call
really appreciate it sure so I am a I'm
a resident physician and my wife and I
have been on the Ramsey plan for about a
year year and a half
been able to debt snowball about forty
thousand dollars worth of our small
debts but I still got about 300 000 in
student loans and like I know right
um my question is there's a lot of
companies willing to hire residents
where you sign a contract you know say
three years early they do prepayment
they do student loan forgiveness and you
know it's all rolled into the scene but
then you're kind of signing yourselves
over to them under contract for say a
certain number of years
and I guess what I'm wondering is is it
wise to get that money now and early
from a future employer but locking
yourself into one of these jobs or
should I wait until I finish residency
and and just start fresh then
probably get the same kind of deals then
can't you
yeah you can get similar ones um I guess
there's some it just depends on the plan
you get some of them they'll like match
your residency salary so instead like
right now I'm making 67 000 a year so to
like match that so you kind of double
that early so then you can get paid off
and you know hopefully pay less interest
overall would be so they'll throw 67 a
year while you're in residency or one
time at the student loans
roughly I mean they advertise like six
seven usually it turns out being about
you know 40 or so
I'm sorry they advertised 67 but they
lied
well well they don't lie they say we
career match but then you know read the
sign for the career matches up to an X
number of dollars well then it's a
matter of negotiation
right
it's a matter for you to negotiate your
new job so how many years would you have
to commit three
uh yeah usually it's about three or four
and your benefit to doing that would be
this one-time signing bonus of forty to
seventy thousand dollars right
um yeah is there another benefit for a
year
so I mean I guess not another benefit
that I would get right now
um but you know other benefits like
student loan payments but I think you
can negotiate it so whether well they
will give you the student loan payment
now so that helps you to not build
interest over the next few years it'll
tell you you know really yeah so forty
to sixty thousand or seventy thousand
now and you sign and for that you're
trading out you're promising to work for
them for three years what and but during
the time you go to work for them then in
addition they would pay down student
loans is that what you're saying
right usually they'll pay like a certain
certain number per year and again it's
all depends on which program you end up
in but sometimes it'll be like 30 000 a
year to a maximum of a hundred thousand
dollars worth of your student loans or
something like that yeah so if you can
get
um you know like 70 now and another 150
over that three years towards this and
get a competitive salary a competitive
pay rate then yeah I would look at doing
those deals but there's nothing to say
you need to sign that you have to sign
up I wouldn't sign up for 40 Grand a day
if that's all you're getting out of this
and you give up three years of of
flexibility because you might make more
than 40 Grand a year extra working for
somebody else
yeah I completely agree the way you set
up at first is like they may give a
total loan forgiveness it's not that
it's not it's not the whole enchilada so
I think you have to weigh what you can
make on your own in that three-year
period versus the 40 and I'm I'm with
Dave if you come out without one of
these contracts what's going to be your
pay rate do you think
so
um depending on where you're willing to
work and it's usually between about 200
and 300 000 or if you you know work it
somewhere that's more like critical
access you can I've seen as high as that
400 to 450 000.
so I'd go that route to knock out all my
loans I'd do a short term in that
critical do something and bust it coming
right out of residency but either one of
those is a fantastic option you can pay
this off yeah I don't think you know
when you start talking about 300 or 200
300 400 in one sentence you don't you
don't you don't sell that chance for 40.
the difference in 300 or the difference
in 200 and 400 you don't sell that
chance for 40. so you've got it you've
got to do it that's the whole thing and
um you know no I'm probably not signing
up given this I I'm with Ken I think you
explore all your options and you
maximize the pay for a short period of
time as soon as you come out and you go
bananas and knock this out I mean good
Lord if you could go make 450 somewhere
and work there two years you could put
so much money in the bank and be debt
free it'd be unbelievable and then go do
whatever you want to do after that
that's option A absolutely well said I
mean I'd do that if he can transition
back to where he really wants to be it's
a no-brainer go bust it for two years
obviously in a specialty yes he's not
doing General practicing right yeah if
you're coming out of school straight
into 450 you're doing something there so
I don't know I didn't ask what that was
but you're obviously doing something
pretty incredible Cody so
um yeah I would lay back in the weeds
and get a better deal let's get let's
get a better deal don't don't sell
yourself for 40 Grand here it's not
worth it
um now am I if we could reverse the
trend and say uh you could have signed
up at the beginning of this for zero
student loans and they pay it all in
return you promise to work for them for
three years and then you did that at the
beginning of med school yeah and you
never took out a student loan day one
I'd make that trade absolutely that's
what I thought it was leaning towards
that's right I'd make that trade that's
uh you know that that's in a sense going
in the military yeah and they pay for it
right I mean that's the same thing so
absolutely I'm going to trade three
years of promise to work for someone uh
for 100 or 200 uh in return for free
yeah med school this is interesting I
want to give Cody some love Dave but
there's an interesting psychology thing
happening here he's going he was
considering this because he's like I
just want to start paying this down so
his heart's in the right place yeah you
know but you don't want to take that
trade off just to make some progress
instead of finishing the residency the
debt's still going to be there and don't
trade 40 today for 200 a year from two
years from now that's exactly right yeah
that's the bottom line and that's what I
thought I was hearing by the time we got
to the bottom of that all right open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five uh there's all kinds
of ways to go to college debt free
uh the most well-known in the medical
world is the MD PhD program where you
are going after your PhD while working
towards your md a lot of work there
involved very few of those seats
available but if you can get one of
those seats you're basically an employee
of the University so all your education
is free
because you're working a fellowship
while you're doing this and you can get
in that program that's a way to get
through you can go through undergrad all
the time debt free
and you just have to choose a proper
college that you can pay for you have to
work all the time and you don't work for
minimum wage
that's it's very doable check out
Anthony O'Neill's book at Ramsey
Solutions called debt free degree teach
your teenagers how not to take out that
[Music]
thank you
internet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is host of the Ken
Coleman show and the author of the
number one bestseller the proximity
principle and a brand new book that we
launched for sale today called from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
doing work you love it's an absolutely
incredible book we are excited about
getting the pre-sale going today the
books will ship November the 9th along
with a hundred dollars worth of goodies
which includes the audiobook the e-book
access to some live streams access to
all kinds of different reports and
issues to help you with your career all
kind a whole bundle of goodies you can
check it all out at ramsaysolutions.com
and uh find out what's there in other
words the advantage to ordering a book
today that comes out and will be shipped
to you November the 9th is that you get
a much better deal and you know working
at your dream job it's uh this is an
important thing because it changes the
whole the whole feel of your life you
don't feel like you're running on
treadmill anymore no and you feel as
though there's more to your job than
just a paycheck and it's about impact
everybody wants to make a contribution
and when you make that unique
contribution that you were created to
make uh watch that purpose wash over you
you're going to be a better spouse a
better parent
a better teammate and there's all kinds
of data that backs us up you can go on
and on and on and on and on about people
that just feel as though I'm just
working for the weekend and we know
inherently that there's more than that
nobody else ever has to teach a person
to ask the question why am I here the
answer is to contrib attribute and you
can contribute through your work and you
should well and when you do it changes
the chemistry of your body it changes
the quality of your relationships it
changes your paycheck it changes how
good you are at your job it changes
everything so this is the proven clear
path
that will walk anyone in any industry
with any level of experience through a
step-by-step plan to help you find
meaningful work and you can pre-order
today you pick between the get hired
Bonus Pack if you're trying to get a
whole new career or the get promoted
bonus pack and you'll get either one of
those free over a hundred dollar value
get promoters if you're already kind of
in the zone but you just want to move
along faster so you're further up the
pathway these these stages of getting uh
to work that you love
so check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com it's all only twenty
dollars with over a hundred dollars
worth of free bonus items from paycheck
to purpose the clear path to doing work
that you love also while you're at
Ramsey Solutions be sure and check out
the 500 cash giveaway every week the
month of August and a grand prize of
three thousand dollars the end of August
no purchase is necessary for that you
can enter daily for extra chances to win
the Ramsey cash giveaway you have to be
18 or older to win text the word cash to
33 789 and you can enter the giveaway
right this second text the word cash two
three three seven eight nine and again
while you're over there you can go ahead
and pick up for 20 bucks the new book
pre-ordered today from paycheck to
purpose in addition to that we launched
today the get clear assessment and uh
you can take that today we've got to
know your yourself money assessment for
couples from Rachel Cruz so several
different assessments that you can do
for just a few dollars you can begin
begin to get a handle on where you are
they get clear assessment is going to
walk you through everything it's 30
bucks to go through it or you can get it
for uh the master bundle the big bundle
with Ken's new book for 30 bucks and you
get the book and all the goodies too
which is the way to do that it really is
if you're going to do that if you're
going to take that assessment now go
ahead and order the book and everything
with it that's the best bargain out
there and the assessment is incredible
it really is it's very practical you're
going to get a detailed report on what
you do best talent wise you're going to
get a detailed report on the work you
love to do we call that passion and then
you're going to get a detailed report on
the results that you get fired up about
putting into the world that's what we
call Mission you're going to get a
populated purpose statement you can hang
it on your wall your mirror it's going
to give you tremendous confidence
through the clarity and then we even
give you a very Clear Directions like a
neon arrow pointing to the marketplace
we call it professional possibilities
you know there's a lot of people out
there listening that that probably have
taken string finders uh 2.0 a strengths
test well that's one-third of the
equation and you didn't get anything
else beyond that it's wonderful tool
this tool gives you a great perspective
and points you to work that you love
that you'll never want to stop doing
because you know you're making your
contribution and I got to tell you Dave
I was really Blown Away by the cash
giveaway 500 cash giveaway every week
this month and then the grand prize of
three thousand that money right there
could go a long way towards paying off
some debt which gets you closer to
pursuing this or it might pay for stage
two get qualified certification these
days can cost you not very much you know
as opposed to college so this cash can
be used and put right to work in the
seven stages and pay for that get
qualified stage so really cool don't
miss that opportunity good stuff good
stuff the get clear assessment available
now as well as the from paycheck to
purpose uh the clear path to doing work
that you love the book new book is on
pre-sale immediately all at
ramseysolutions.com and register for the
free cash while you're there Adam is
with us in Cincinnati hi Adam how are
you
great Dave Ken thanks for taking my call
sure what's up hey yeah I've got a baby
step five question about saving for kids
college I've got a three-year-old
daughter and a nine-month-old son but
I've been paralyzed in baby step five
because I can't figure out a savings
Target to aim for now I know how to
project a cost into the future based on
inflation but there's two variables that
I can't figure out how to factor into my
savings Target first I teach at a
private liberal arts university which
offers a 90 tuition remission benefit
now I have no plans to leave in 15 years
but I don't know if I can Bank on that
either and second my parents have had a
529 set up for my kids and there's about
thirty five thousand dollars in that to
get us going I have no reason to think
the money won't be there but I also
don't know how to bank on that so in 15
years sarcastically I think I'll need
somewhere between thirty thousand and
three hundred thousand dollars per kid
but I don't really know how to set a
savings Target even though smart
investor Pro that we consulted with was
a little bit stumped so it's hoping you
could help me out
okay
um
I would I would I would make two
assumptions uh and this will help narrow
your variables down I would make the
assumption that the 529 is going to be
in your control and I would ask for it
to be done for it to be turned over for
you to be the custodian of it
um because I have to be able to control
it to put it in our planning mom and dad
and I think they'll probably do that
unless they unless they don't trust you
with the money
um I don't think that's it they're
differently followers too so no reason
not to trust them but yeah that's a good
plan then the second variable is I would
not count on you being there
uh-huh you might be and if you are
that's an added that's gravy on the
biscuit but I would run my assumptions
with control of the 529 and not count on
the free tuition of the 90 tuition
um and then from there I would back up
and say okay let's pretend I'm not
working at this private liberal arts
university
are where are my kids are going to go to
school
and you need to go ahead and have that
as your Target and so in our case we
said State School in-state tuition and
dorms and dorm food and you can run the
numbers on that and you know you can
find out what that costs today in Ohio
and you'll find it to be about 10 grand
a year roughly maybe 10 to 12 most of
them are somewhere right in that range
for in-state tuition plus room and board
and probably another 10 grand so today
it's about 80.
to go through somewhere in that range
um give or take okay uh and you can go
look at it you can do I do the actual
research
um and then you can add some inflation
to that and you'll be right on track and
so you know if you say I got a brand new
baby we're gonna at least double it so
we're probably looking at 200. and now
you got your target you know but or if
you gotta if you got one going in two
years your 80's probably gonna be pretty
close but somewhere in that 60 to 80
range we'll put a kid through right now
plus or minus Community College plus or
minus in state tuition plus or minus
staying at home and not having dorm and
dorm food so you just got to look at you
can start to make some assumptions to
Dollar then but you can't say I'm gonna
have no limits on where they go to
school they can spend 300 000 a year
you can't plan for that
um you don't have enough money
God doesn't have that much money I'm
kidding but he does but
please don't do that it's not worth it
no I wouldn't spend it
[Music]
oh my gosh this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Matthew
and Brittany are with us hey guys how
are you what's going on hi Dave welcome
welcome where do you all live Portsmouth
Virginia all right cool and all the way
to Nashville to do a debt free scream
how much have you paid off
166
325. wow how long did that take four
years and five months wow good for you
and your range of income during that
time uh 97 to 1 30. good what do you all
do for a living I am a Metrology
technician I work in victim witness at a
local state attorney's office wow
neither one of you have uncomplicated
things with your life oh my gosh wow
what kind of debts the 166 000 was it
the majority of it was student loans on
my end oh oh yeah oh yeah uh we had the
uh the van the uh medical bills a little
small credit card but the majority of it
was student loans how long have you guys
been married uh coming on 11 years okay
so halfway through the marriage
ding ding you wake up and you go
something needs to change tell me the
story what happened
so it actually started in 2013 so it
took us a few years to totally get on
board with this process we were pregnant
with our twins who are here today and my
grandfather Pope gifted us FPU wow so we
took the class and we just didn't really
believe we could do it at that point we
we were kind of doing it ish as you say
we we were following a budget but we
weren't completely on board we weren't
ready to completely dive in and just
dedicate everything to it and be that
gazelle intents that you talk about
um and I'll never forget the Twins were
two
and our youngest was probably like six
months
and we got a uh bill in the mail
and we found out we had a student loan
that we didn't know about oh and that
was probably the scariest moment
wow
and that's when we knew we were we were
ready that was right that was it that
was Rock Bottom for sure oh crap Mama
yeah yep how much was the loan a little
over I think it was right at 20. so an
extra 20 000 just shows up the mailbox
one day yep oh man that will take your
breath away yeah it did but it's what we
needed to realize that we just had to to
go all in and we were ready at that
point we
um
it was interesting because we that night
we just prayed about it like how can we
do this we have to do this and within
like a couple weeks I randomly got this
job offer out of the blue
um that was a significant more than I
what I was making at the time
um and we just took that as a sign and
we just ran with it cool so you get the
old FPU kid out and blow the dust off or
what
um or you go back yeah we went back to a
class okay good then we started
coordinating it oh and that actually it
kind of kicks you into gear there
um and we um we didn't want to be the
Hypocrites you know yeah so uh we got
gazelle we started grinding and grinding
uh and did it for that long uh it was uh
it was a long track
yes yes sir so first of all I got to
tell you I'm from the 757. I'm a Hampton
Roads yeah so I wanted to shout out some
local folks there so the 97 130 was that
what happened there give me the details
there what jumped it up uh so
OT over time on my end um how many hours
were you pulling oh I I can't even think
it was a it was a it was a blur it was
that many I was just anytime I could get
it I got it yeah so is it worth it yeah
absolutely you were bone tired but it
was working oh man absolutely so how
much of the 166 was paid off in the last
year of the four years uh about 53. okay
so you paid off the most in that yeah
yes sir so once you got the momentum it
just plowed it rolled right downhill yes
and I think that was like a huge
motivator too and doing it like how you
talk about it is it just it shows that
it works and it shows that after you pay
each debt off you can just keep paying
more and more towards the next one you
know every every year we would sit down
and and get a goal for the full year and
then we would separate it for for the
month and having in those small goals is
what there's little celebrations of of
moving somewhere you know you're on
track yes sir
we probably two years prior said we're
gonna do this in March of 2021. so that
was our goal long before we we made it
and that's when we paid it off I believe
it was wow March 15th wow look at you
impressive and covet didn't stop it nope
nope help it or hurt it
uh neutral a little bit he didn't get
overtime at that point but yeah but at
that point I think we were we were so
close yeah so you're pushing it on
through way to go you guys I'm so proud
of you what do you tell people now that
your coordinators and you actually paid
off 166
000 in debt what do you tell people the
key is to get out of debt never give up
never give up especially those who know
it's going to take a while yeah you know
you just gotta keep going and you know
the
the the marathon right the you got to
get to that finish line one step at a
time so that's what I would say we were
definitely the the tortoise in the race
but you know like you say slow and
steady wins and that's that's what we
did
um I think another key for us is after
each debt we paid off we would do
something to kind of celebrate that debt
like all right we paid this off we're
gonna go to a nice dinner and then just
buckle down and put our heads down until
we get to the next one it was just you
know little little things like that
along the way that made a huge
difference I tell you there's three
reasons right over there where it'll get
you going yes sir get you back up
um waking up you know really early for
me uh and and just grinding all those
hours those three little boys over there
will get you going now you got the rest
of your life that's right now that
you're free how's it feel feels great
amazing I can't believe it's here those
are worth it absolutely where you go
back into it no sir not for anything not
for anything ever ever I have you on
video now this is your video testimony
go ahead
I love that
well done guys so proud of y'all all
right bring the boys over let's
introduce them what are their names and
ages this is Jew
five and these are our twins Finn and
Hudson they're seven ah also known as
win the student loan payment came yeah
yeah I love it the extra piling on of
the student loan all right that's very
cool well you guys look like you're
worth it I think you're worth it I think
you're worth your family tree changing
you got your mom and dad are heroes
they're absolutely incredible very very
well done we got a copy of the Legacy
Journey for you that's the next chapter
in your story for sure an extra copy of
The Total Money Makeover giveaway and
pay it forward thank you for leading the
class you've been paying it forward
already showing other people the way I'm
so proud of y'all very very well done
impressive impressive people all right
Matthew Brittany Finn Hudson and Jude
from Norfolk 166
000 paid off four years and five months
of grind 97 to 130 was the income
counted down let's hear a debt free
scream 30 guys three two one
well done boys yeah boys bring it bring
it I love it that is fun
you guys tune in and you listen to that
real careful you can hear those little
boys screaming up through their parents
microphone
if you didn't know what the sound of a
family tree changing sounds like
you just heard it yeah
that's the sound of a change
a permanent change yeah I've opened up
the mailbox and gotten out something
that did that to me yeah it's a knife to
the throat
an extra 20 000 and she she remembered
it years ago when tears came years ago
if you're watching that on YouTube and
you see Britney's tears
and she only stopped crying to be able
to gut scream we're debt free she was
remembering it but now she's on the
other side of it that's beautiful that's
Freedom that's just unbelievable what a
great family you guys are rock stars
very cool this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
45 2 I will go before you and will level
the mountains I will break down Gates of
bronze and cut through bars of iron
Thomas Edison said when you have
exhausted all possibilities remember
this
you haven't
[Laughter]
you do yes there is I like that Dave's
with us in Madison Wisconsin hi Dave
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave
and I I wish I was calling for a
different reason but um my mother-in-law
is a ward of the state she has Ms she's
in a nursing home she's been there for
quite a few years she had to go have a
medical procedure at a local hospital
because she had sepsis for about the
third or fourth time and we have been
getting bills from that local hospital
for months now and the nursing home and
said well you know she's on Medicare or
I'm sorry Medicaid and obviously has no
money and so
um you know they're supposed to take
care of it but yet once again we keep
getting these bills and now uh you know
I just got one today saying you know my
mother-in-law is seriously delinquent
and that they're gonna take further
action and and uh you know send it to
collections and so I guess I'm wondering
she has no money and she's in a nursing
home a ward of the state there's no she
has nothing does she own anything
no she can't
you know they take her social security
check every month and obviously that
doesn't cover the cost of the it's a
County nursing home yeah um so that that
doesn't come near close enough to cover
why are the Bills coming to your house
that's well so my my wife is the power
of attorney oh she's an only only child
okay and so she has to make all the
decisions financially yeah and so when
um when my my mother-in-law's husband
died my wife's stepfather
um you know they didn't have an address
anymore and so it became our address and
so my wife is very concerned that now
stuff's coming to our address and that
we're gonna get some knock at the door
from some collection Bozo that's gonna
try to shake us down for money well you
know you're you're you don't owe any
money so he can shake all he wants he
can Shake Rattle and Roll right out to
his car and leave there's nothing I mean
besides that people don't do
door-to-door collections hardly anymore
except on really redneck stuff so
they're not gonna fool with you on this
um uh but what I would do is as the
power of attorney I would contact them
by mail uh certified mail return turn
receipt requested and just say I'm
acting as her power of attorney she is
penniless she is a ward of the state
your only hope of collecting this bill
is through Medicare here's the nursing
home that takes care of all that
[Laughter]
and sic'em on the nursing home
because that's who should have taken
care of this by the way that's how
Medicaid Medicare somebody should have
picked that up and they're supposed to
be running that over there so they
should have filed these claims if
there's a claim you can file on your
mother-in-law's behalf that's fine if
your wife wants to do that if there's
some Medicaid Medicare process she can
help help the hospital collect their
money from Medicaid or Medicare that'd
be wonderful but you in no case end up
owing something because you're the power
of attorney
there's no such thing
okay because yeah I it turns into I try
to be supportive and I just get mad and
then it doesn't go very well there's
nothing to get mad about this is just
the government inefficiencies of life
Medicare Medicaid is the DMV of the
medical world
I mean you're just in line trying to get
your license I mean it just takes you
know it's just a pain in the butt
nothing about it is efficient nothing
about it runs properly
um but we all need socialized medicine
right because it just crap and so uh you
know you're just dealing with the
welfare state dude and so uh you know
your wife can put some effort into it
and probably should on her Mom's behalf
to try to make sure the claims get filed
properly with Medicaid Medicare as your
mom's rep as her mom's representative
rather is the power of attorney but
you're under no financial obligation and
so what I do is jump on the phone with
the nursing home jump on the phone with
the hospital administrator and say hey
look this is a Medicaid Medicare claim
how can I help you get that done because
obviously she's not going to pay it and
we're not going to pay it she can't pay
it and obviously we're not liable so um
yeah but I mean as her power of attorney
I'm more than willing to assign whatever
forms you got to help you guys get paid
okay because she's tried to contact the
hospital and they just say well it's
gone to collection so we can't talk to
you anymore well that's perfect dumb
butts
and then the idiot collections that
person who's been on the job four and a
half days is gonna call you know until
so I mean I lived a pound sand I would
just give them the number to the nurses
yeah just give them the name of the
nursing home and just say you can talk
to her she's got dementias you all will
get along well oh my God unfortunately
unfortunately she does and she hasn't
she would have no idea what anybody
would be talking about I'm sorry that's
tacky but but I mean that's the truth is
is that you're dealing with it you know
it's a horrible horrible system and it's
obviously inefficient so yeah when they
call just say you need to contact
nursing home we can't help you uh if you
guys want to send the Medicare stuff
over here we can assign the power of
attorney but I'm not having a bunch of
discussions with you idiots
and because dude you got somebody
literally that's been on the job four
and a half days gonna call you uh
because collectors don't keep their jobs
very long because they would rather
clean out septic tanks than do the job
of collecting and so as soon as the
septic tank job comes open they leave
right a turnover turnover is just
incredible they have a sheet in front of
them I'm not operating I'm not kidding
it's four and a half days that guy's
been on the on the phones before he
calls you so it's it's a mess so I'm
sorry I'm sorry y'all going through this
but the good news is Dave
um you you guys aren't going to owe the
money uh and so you can you can exert as
much energy as you want to out of a
sense of loyalty or honor to her mom as
the power of attorney but you're going
to find you know I called up and tried
to help you fill out the forms always
can't help you we send to collections
that's my favorite there you go kiss my
butt that's it that's the end of this
discussion you know oh my God
unbelievable all right Frank's with us
in Philadelphia Frank welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Ken hey Dave thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
question about going into debt for the
purpose of buying into a medical
practice as a physician
um there's a little bit of a different
situation with this particular uh buy-in
it's not buying into a traditional
independently owned practice
um it's a practice that's getting
acquired by a private Equity Group
and I just want to get your thoughts on
that type of situation it's kind of a
trend in medicine so so how are you
buying in if a private Equity group's
buying it well so the private Equity
Group is acquiring the practice so the
current owners of the practice which I'm
not an owner right now are obviously you
know they're getting their their buyout
but then in order to keep people with
skin in the game and to stay
incentivized all the all the Physicians
have to buy into this new platform so
the platform is basically a group of
several practices across a large region
that's owned by the private Equity Group
and they keep the Physicians sort of you
know vested and incentivized by having
you know having a small piece of the
game and it's like
um yeah listen
[Music]
um
my tolerance for debt is very low my
tolerance for private Equity is even
lower
um and across multiple platforms where
you have absolutely no control you're
going to buy in you're what's known as a
minority shareholder at best which means
you have absolutely no power and they're
going to give to you what they want to
give to you as a return
meaning they could choose to run this
thing in the dirt and make your share
worth nothing
not because they would do it on purpose
but because they were idiots
yeah I mean this this particular
platform has been around for several
years right now and they have been very
it's been well run and it's been
profitable
um I mean it's up to you doc if you want
to do it I wouldn't do it run I don't do
private Equity deals I don't get
involved with those characters and I
don't do minority share positions I
don't care what the track record is on
it and I sure as crud don't go in debt
to do all that so I I personally
wouldn't do it but you certainly got to
make your decision thank you for the
call again Coleman James Childs Kelly
Daniel good show today I'm Dave Ramsey
your host we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
this is James Childs producer of the
Ramsey show you can listen to all our
shows with the Ramsay Network app on
your smartphone Browse by topic or even
sync Clips to your friends
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]